they rejected it they said a cartoon  image of Donald Trump going Super Saiyan  was political  why  now now that now I'm deeply offended I  just wanted to sell a t-shirt of Donald  Trump with with Goku here you can't even  do that apparently  go ahead sorry oh no  wait I how did they determine what's  political because I've only used the  promotion feature once on YouTube and it  was or not YouTube on Twitter and it was  to promote a YouTube video that was not  largely political but it was there were  politics involved in the video so how  did they determine what's political it's  Trump yeah they didn't want a a cartoon  of trump that makes him look good they  don't want to take the money for that or  something well my video was an hour long  and it was political at some points but  they I guess didn't want to watch an  hour long video to figure that part out  the image isn't even Pro or anti-trump  it's just meant to be silly it's Trump  with you know spiky blonde hair